the biggest study ever on the pay Gap I
think was done by Harvard basically
looked at Uber drivers in America the
big reason was the biggest because he
had so much data Uber obviously has so
much data and men and women both Drive
Ubers in America they looked at the
paying and they were like well women are
getting paid less at Uber how does that
make sense because it's obviously all
automated what a great way of studying
male or female Behavior to work out what
is in this Gap and there's three things
in the Gap the first was men drove at
different times a night so men would do
the graveyard shifts early mornings were
getting paid more they would want to do
that women less so the second was that
men were more likely to stick with the
platform for longer so they had more
experiences and they benefited from that
experience makes sense of any job and
the third reason which is 50 of the Gap
was that men just drive faster
so drive a little faster guys then
you'll close that Gap that shows it
wasn't discrimination that's causing the
pay Gap in Uber it was just a heavy
right foot different types of behavior
and I guess we could have discussion of
what shapes that behavior but we need to
start that conversation with it's not
discrimination at least an Uber
different types of behavior